like a dude can be 50 and a girl that's
30 will still find him fine but like
it's not the same vice versa you could
be 50 and a [ __ ] and you're not
attractive as a guy yeah you could be a
guy correct you have all the money in
the world but you just know well mostly
don't turn women on correct most men
have died a lot like yeah I think that
we're only 40 only only 40 only 40 of
men have reproduced throughout history
so where 80 of women have so the
majority of men do die alone you're
right it's just a new thing for women
because like they they get because they
don't listen to what men want anymore
so how do we fix that it's coming from
what go ahead how do we like level the
playing field there we're doing it
slowly well I mean to me it's like the
it's the you you get rid of the
consequence more people do it so if you
pay women to leave marriages the more
girls are going to do it they're paid
through child support and through the
government
like when you pay women to make bad
decisions every bad decision we make
were built out of you could be homeless
there's a women's shelter to take care
of you you could sleep around you can
get an abortion to bail you out like
whatever bad decision women make there's
a bailout there's incentives yeah yeah
like like so if you're paid to make bad
decisions more women make bad decisions
like they're not going to stop they're
not going to stop till the consequence
goes away yeah you know that was a big
thing in the country
what'd you say earlier sorry there's uh
she didn't know she didn't hear it and I
said in my day you know women were just
gonna they're getting pregnant together
yeah yeah yeah it's the first time
toilet heard of it and I said yeah
hit reality hard because if a man makes
a bad decision or if he ain't [ __ ] the
world will tell him yeah well they will
feed women lies and let her live in
delusion like even even when I said
you're less valuable when you hit 30
like that shouldn't be that's just life
yeah like almost valuable than I was
when I was 22. it just is what it is it
is what it is it's not it's not a
personal attack on me yeah
honestly honestly to everyone like your
looks are currency girls don't even like
we don't know how good they have it
because you are given more attention and
opportunity because of the way you look
life is on easy mode as a young pretty
girl [ __ ] like hit 50 let life change
but you you're you're like you hate my
eyes you best learn to cook them
we see it every day in the world but
people still choose to argue the fact it
is true as a 21 year old your life was
different to how it is now it is a fact
it is a fact when you were younger you
were more attractive you went out you
you felt fresher no it's not about being
to me honestly no honestly I'm gonna I'm
gonna ask you something then
um it happened to me to have many
friends they actually prefer like date
older they're trying they're trying to
[ __ ] you yeah
all right guys
may I make the point men are trying to
[ __ ] you at 20 years old girl as a 15
years old woman that's not different
they are thinking just to
I don't want to be rude but like you
know what I mean they are thinking about
that from the principle so if uh old
women get you know less attractive
whatever it is so anyway that's quite
good looking 15 years old women that
they actually dating 20 or 30 years old
man
it's not even remember no no it's not
it's not it's not even like honestly me
personally I add friends very good look
six foot guys very good looking guys
they actually dated older women also
child did they marry them well what in
terms it doesn't count unless you get a
ring for me like this is what I'm saying
it doesn't count unless he commits to
you for life so yeah like 26 years old
give him the time to get married I could
I could I could say okay I dated a guy
that was a millionaire does that mean
make me a millionaire wife no no no yeah
results the results so first of all
that's not the result for myself because
I uh 20 years old women who can get
married when she's 22 so she's so
valuable or whatever she got a lot of
eggs she can be left alone when she is
25 and the uzban is sleeping around
around and gonna left her alone looking
after the child so what about the value
we're talking about she's still 25 she
give you a best life her best chance and
she is she is by herself now so what
about this what about this go ahead I'm
gonna say why don't you get married
before she had the kid no no I said you
getting a 20 years old women with lot of
eggs you know beautiful and and
everything so very you know up up
standards
not childless okay so you get married
with her you get you got a pregnant so
let's say you got one child or whatever
now how many cases we know about men
leaving the house with the child
children oh men still cheating on them
cheating
guys if she was available so why it went
outside to looking for others because
because cheating is different for men
and for women men can have sex with a
phone and what about when they leave the
cheese
no women women women
stop yelling stop stop you you just
you're yelling okay women leave 70 to 80
of the time 90 if you have a college
degree 90 of the time you're leaving
Man
by and large are not leaving so that's
not who do you men and women cheat at
equal rates I
know a lot of a lot of a lot of children
left alone from their dad okay I know a
lot of single mothers and they've been
left alone okay you can you can know it
but you can look at who files divorce
the difference they probably never even
get married but
the difference from what she's saying
is that the big difference is what you
said that he married her yeah that gives
her status who cares if he's sleeping
out she's covered up she goes to get
married that's what I was gonna say
thank you
guys the man sorry Auntie Jenny just
give me one second guys I'm gonna
reiterate the rules because we're not
getting there one at a time people at
home can't hear you it's a great
conversation I want you guys to have
this conversation but I need to be able
to hear you so please allow each other
to speak one at a time thank you let's
get into it you got
a young girl you said 25 with a kid
and the man marries her Lisa goes and
sleeps out you got a 25 yeah yeah you
got a 25 year old woman
not married the man has a kid with one
loser who's at the better advice the one
that got married
because she can take everything because
they're making everything about status
and what Society think about women
so she's gonna be results
that's like me saying I'm an Olympian
with no metal
like like women live like this is what I
mean like you're like that's delusion
you can go through life living in
delusion
came like focusing
yeah
if I if I have a ring then I am
protected I if I I okay okay you your
mic is off because you keep interrupting
me if I have a ring that I'm entitled
like then I'm protected legally I'm
protected legally
from from you okay do you not do you not
know
League
you can turn it on God oh I was on mute
this whole time okay but if if he if
he's cheated on you like a 20 year old
he's married her she's young she's got
eggs whatever dude he's married her
they've had vowels they've had a child
and he's cheated she's okay because
she's got a ring he's racist
because he married her that's what's the
most important thing and then and then
there's a side chicken and the wife I
hadn't finished sorry so so you said
that there was the 20 year old who got
married had a baby and he cheated and
then you got the 25 year old who had a
baby but didn't get married and he
cheated or let's just say they're both
the same age right right the one that
had a ring is more special because she
got a ring she's more protected okay
she's protected by law because his
husband wife
yeah exactly so like let's say so so
because sorry I hadn't finished so
because she's protected by the ring that
makes her more valuable because she's
got the medal
no because you cut in and didn't let me
finish okay go on so then sorry I've
just you just said the result was the
ring but the result was he she got
cheated okay cool okay allowed to finish
a lot all right cool no it's just like
they're both they're they're both at a
loss it's not one is better than the
other they're both equal